[Musique]
merci jimmy bonjour à vous bonjour à
vous toutes et vous tous et bonjour je
suis une placide
bonjour bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique la première merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes la
directrice générale de la darpa
l'association départementale dead aux
retraités et personnes âgées
la darpa une association martiniquaise
dédié donc à l'accompagnement des
seniors dans les activités de la vie
quotidienne et c'est une institution
dans notre paysage social et économique
puisque la darpa été fondée en 1970 mais
nous ne sommes pas là pour regarder vers
le passé avec vous je signe placide mais
pour parler du présent et de l'avenir et
l'actualité
c'est cette vaccination ces vaccinations
contre les effets les plus graves de
lakovic 19 comment vivez vous cette
nouvelle phase de la lutte contre la
pandémie à la darpa
oui en effet il y à une phase de
vaccination une programmation de
vaccination qui est prévu par par l'état
et chênois l'ana ont pas je n'obligerait
pas le personnel notamment aidé à
domicile à se faire vacciner encore
puisque bon ce sera un choix
merci duels individuels de chaque
salarié
ce que nous avons quand même 160
salariés qui interviennent au domicile
des pays qui sont au contact et qui sont
quotidiennement des personnes âgées donc
les personnes nées l'été les plus primés
mais dites moi le vaccin c'est d'abord
pour se protéger soi la taf
donc on va parler des personnes âgées
mais vous parlez des personnels médicaux
bien sûr c'est pas obligatoire donc
c'est eux qui décideront
même s'il prenait le vaccin il serait
obligé de continuer à adopter les gestes
barrière il faut le rappeler le vase des
nues les effets de la maladie mais
n'empêche pas jusqu'à preuve du
contraire alors on parle la transmission
d'être contagieux absolument tout ce que
nous nous faisons ce rappel très
régulièrement aux intervenantes à
domicile pour le respect des gestes
marièrent le port du masque notamment et
s'il ya possibilité d'être un distance
ce qui est très rare par rapport à la
situation il faut le faire mais il est
vrai que le vaccin ce n'est pas ce qui
est mis en avant chez nous en ce moment
rappelons rappelons juste juste plaisir
parce qu'en effet pendant la période de
crise nous n'avons pas eu de cas avérés
de
deux personnes à tête parmi vos
personnels parmi nos personnels et aussi
note parmi les personnes sanctionnées
rechargement les voilà les règles de bon
et et les règles des gestes barrières
ont été certainement serait très bien
prête à appliquer et respecter
jocelyne classique directrice générale
de la darpa je voulais demander quel
effet plus globalement de cette crise
sanitaire sur vos activités vos missions
alors je rappel essentiellement vos
missions vous êtes une association qui
s'est spécialisé dans les services d
aide à domicile pour les personnes âgées
et les personnes retraitées
tous avouent émission nos missions
principales effectivement son d'elena
domicile auprès des personnes âgées
aussi aux personnes en situation de
handicap ils iront à tout public mais
essentiellement auprès des personnes
âgées nous avons aussi un service au
public qui ont peut-être des difficultés
actifs ou des choses comme ça nos actifs
oui par exemple oui vous pouvez faire
appel à nos services pour intervenir
chez vous les seniors non non pas
forcément à force à d'accord c'est un
forcément s'il avait vraiment élargi aux
seulement votre champ d'intervention et
nous avons aussi un service de soins
infirmiers à domicile ce que je voulais
souligner j'étais revenu sur les droites
sud de la martinique
et nous avons également une
établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées valides et autonomes au
carbet oui je vous demander quels effets
de la crise sanitaire parce que j'ai
retrouvé un article de sur notre site un
qui date de mars du début de l'épidémie
quoi et on disait que les services data
domicile restent opérationnels en
martinique
les prestations sont garanties assure la
darpa et la ctm
oui j'avais eu d'interruption de phase
ii tous les gars à la darpa à l'ana ont
pas c'est vrai que nous avons tenu à
maintenir nos prestations puisque comme
vous l'avez dit c'est un public
vulnérable souvent isolés donc on ne
pouvait pas du jour au lendemain laissé
tomber
c'est vrai qu'au début de l'adhérent je
crois mille adhérents
l'interprète génère pas au niveau dans
le service d'aidé à domicile au début de
la crise nous avions un problème qui a
été l'équipement des salariés bien que
nous avons nous ayons réagi très
rapidement passant commande mais pour
les masques ont été bloqués au niveau
des services de l'état
mais après c'est vrai qu'après la ctm a
pu nous équiper notamment masques
angèle un solution hydro alcoolique et
nous avons aussi fait l'acquisition de
quelques équipements mais par contre
nous avons tenu à maintenir l'activité
nous avons une réduction d'activité de
30%
oui parfois certains salariés qui
n'étaient pas qui avait dû être arrêté
et aussi par rapport à certaines
personnes qui refusaient la prestation
par peur du duc ovine 19 et nous avons
une baisse d'activité de 3 et de
recevoir de se voir la prestation nous
sommes entré également en contact avec
la famille pour le relais 1 par rapport
à la baisse d'activité et nous avions
fonctionner à 70 % de notre activité en
tous les cas entre mars et mai voilà
maintenant près de 9 du mois après vous
s'éroder au mois de juin on a repris
l'activité
on va parler des moyens de vos missions
maintenant parce qu'on sait que la darpa
a connu des périodes très difficiles a
été presque au bord me semble-t-il du
redressement judiciaire si ce n'est pas
passé un moment par le redressement
judiciaire je crois par une procédure de
redressement judiciaire
on vous en êtes maintenant excusez moi
voilà vos missions votre action repose
et s'appuie beaucoup sur le soutien de
la collectivité territoriale
travailleurs essentiellement beaucoup
énormément à plus de 50 % de notre
activité avec la collectivité
territoriale de martinique la situation
de la darpa s'est améliorée mais
n'oublions pas que
les services d'un à domicile ce sont des
services qui sont en grande difficulté
non seulement sur le territoire de la
martinique mais sur le territoire
national pourquoi parce que non les
moyens financiers ne permettent pas de
couvrir l'ensemble des changes et duit
par cette activité puisque je rappelle
que près de 85 % des charges d'un
service d'aidé à domicile
ce sont les charges de personnel donc
c'est vraiment pas ça s'est amélioré
mais on vous refuse de s'engager on pas
parler de recettes parce que là c'est
une association presque à caractère
dirait humanitaire ou interdites hâtif
mais mais voilà quoi vous aux sources
les précédents subventions certaines
subventions peut-être n'ont pas de
subvention subventions sur l'inflation
malgré seulement des dotations fasse ou
non de la cm des caisses de retraite de
certaines mutuelles d assurances
également et puis de la rs pour le siad
et le service de soins infirmiers est
aussi l'établissement que nous avons au
carbet bon mais alors là l'avenir
comment il se présente de ce point de
vue là point de vue financier budgétaire
pour la darpa
vous pensez que alors il faut savoir que
les services d'aidé à domicile
le financement est si vous voulez et
gérait pas on va dire la cnav la caisse
nationale d'assurance qui fixe un taux
annuel de remboursement des heures
d'aidé à domicile et nous sommes le plus
souvent soumis à ce taux puisque nous
travaillons essentiellement avec des
caisses de retraite la ctm qui est
aujourd'hui la 7ème suisse photo mais le
prix de revient le coût de revient de
services d'aidé à domicile tourne autour
de 23 24 rouleurs donc même au niveau
national c'est une grande difficulté
comme cela n'est pas complètement
concentré finalement ils ont des
difficultés des difficultés j'espère en
voir et encore
absolument pas c'est un acteur très
important sciolla t50 couler souligné
c'est cela qu'on voulait souligner pour
terminer donc notre entretien je suis
une placide directrice générale de la
darpa
on va parler parce que le csm et puis
bon on en entend parler de plus en plus
mais le csm le conseil consultatif
économique social environnemental de la
culture et d'éducation auprès de la ctm
a produit un rapport ya pas longtemps
l'an dernier la précarité économique des
seniors en disant que non seulement il
ya on constate là une paupérisation et
la province mans des seniors mais ça
devrait s'amplifier dans les années à
venir et la ctm devrait s'en saisir
parce que ça va être un problème pour la
société martiniquaise
vous le constatez vous sur le terrain au
contact des personnes ou et absolu de
ces seniors ici absolument c'est un
problème qui qui date de plusieurs
années
effectivement la population se paupérise
puisque nous aurons de plus en plus de
personnes qui vont montrer à la retraite
qui vont partir à la retraite
donc effectivement c'est un sujet que
l'on constate sur le terrain au
quotidien puisque nous travaillons comme
vous l'avez dit auprès de 1000 personnes
et sur 1000 personnes c'est vrai que
beaucoup de personnes bénéficient de
l'aide sociale donc ça se ressent et on
a on a eu une baisse d'activité mais
aujourd'hui on constate une demande de
plus en plus forte des personnes et
effectivement je crois que la ctm
devrait se saisir de cela parce qu'il y
aura un vrai enjeu par rapport dans
quelques années on va dire dans vingt
ans dans quelques années un vrai enjeu
parce que la population
en tous les cas des personnes du même
sexe est corrélée avec une perte
d'autonomie finalement ça entraîne une
perte de l'amplifier oui le manque de
moyens le manque de moyens justement des
personnes âgées est plus si vous voulez
sur le quotidien de ces personnes ce
sont des personnes qui ne pourront pas
le moral et morale absolument ce sont
des personnes qui ne pourront pas
accéder aux soins ce sont des personnes
qui n'auront pas accès aux loisirs qui
vont se renfermer qui vont s'isoler et
justement c'est à ce moment là que la
dépendance va s'installer parce que
c'est vrai qu'avec le manque de moyens
on peut rien faire on peut rien faire
donc c'est pour ça que nous à la danse
en tous les cas on accentue sur la
prévention à la prévention qui est un
facteur est important on doit axer nous
à la dame la septième en tous les cas
même la population martiniquaise doit
s'en rende compte doit prendre en
prendre en compte sa situation sa santé
dès l'âge de 45 ans je dirais bien merci
jocelyne classique je sais c'est court
mais voilà mais nous sommes allés à
l'essentiel
voilà du mit bonne journée